[Musique]
une première en la matière la justice a
ordonné l'expulsion d'une mère de
famille de son hlm après la condamnation
de son fils pour trafic de drogue la
mesure est radicale mais pour marie
jeanne murcia représentants des
locataires de l'office hlm les trafics
et les dégradations était devenue
insoutenable pour beaucoup de voisins
c'est difficile de vivre dans un endroit
où où tout est cassé systématiquement où
il ya du bruit ou il ya où il ya des va
et vient chaque locataire est
responsable
de les personnes qui l'héberge que ce
soit 1,9 me et un enfant qui plus est
français d'un ensemble il ya l'autorité
parentale qui s'applique je veux offrir
à mes locataires une condition de vie
digne sinon ces quartiers se paupérise
rond je trouve un peu
scandaleux pour ne pas dire plus la
réaction du premier adjoint au maire de
nice il dit c'est une victoire bon voilà
on voit bien quand on est rentré dans la
campagne présidentielle et que il ya
aussi beaucoup de parents qui essayent
ils ça ne fonctionne pas et moi je vous
donne un exemple c'est pas pour mais je
me souviens de valérie pécresse qui a eu
un petit souci est que ces enfants pour
des histoires comme ça de
shit ou autre bon un logement social ça
se mérite
bien sûr ça se mérite parce qu'il ya
énormément d'attentes d'ailleurs c'est
compliqué de construire quand on a les
amis verts de monsieur kenner qui nous
ont demandé plus de logements sociaux
qui sont contre toutes les constructions
on a tout essayé depuis des années je
veux dire il ya un moment où
pardonnez-moi la carotte a été essayé
depuis des années il ya un moment il
faut tenter le bâton voilà c'est tout et
on sait très bien que la seule chose qui
fait peur c'est ce genre de sanction
j'espère que cette jurisprudence de nice
fera son effet est que dans les
situations
sensibles que nous connaissons eh bien
nous pourrons avec les bailleurs et et
la justice expulsé un certain nombre de
délinquants un vent de liberté souffle à
rennes loin des talibans ces afghans ou
français d'origine afghane dans son
solidarité avec leur pays et surtout
pour soutenir 45 des leurs coincé en
afghanistan prévisions pour 2022
prévisions de croissance 4%
ks360 pour 2021
4 % pour 2022 ce qui veut dire que nous
maintiendrons un rythme dynamique je dis
qu'aujourd'hui ces personnes sont des
irresponsables et s'y sent pas français
s'il avait obtenu le statut de réfugié
mais qui sont allés passer leurs
vacances en afghanistan c'est peut-être
qu'ils sont pas si réfugiés que ça voilà
il faut arrêter d'être idiot dans ce
pays il ya un championnat d'europe de la
coupe mulet c'était ce week-end dans la
creuse en
vainqueur a été élu à l'applaudimètre il
est belge lbe alias nicolas van der
kelen routier belge a été donc sacré
champion d'europe de la coupe mulet ce
week end la deuxième édition de la
compétition s'est déroulé chénier au
nord de limoges saint sont dignes
descendants de bowie jagger de cyndi
lauper courte devant longue derrière
édition spéciale parce que jean paul
belmondo est décédé on vient d'apprendre
cette nouvelle jean paul belmondo est
décédé 16h28 votre édition qui s'ouvre
sur cette nouvelle qu'on vient
d'apprendre la mort de jean-paul
belmondo nuit à 23h47 le ciel de
bretagne a été traversé par un immense
flash lumineux suivie d'une violente
déflagration du noron
il restera à jamais le magnifique avec
jean paul belmondo c'est un trésor
national tout en gaieté solaire et en
éclats de rire parmi nos grands acteurs
il était celui qui remportait haut la
main la palme du public incroyable
exploit pour voulez vous faire partager
de ce pilote de course il s'appelle
dario costa il a 41 ans et avec son
avion l'italien a traversé deux tunnels
consécutive juste à côté d'istanbul en
turquie plus de 2 km à
245 km heure selon les premières
analyses ce fragment de comètes poserait
un kilo sa vitesse de pénétration dans
l'atmosphère a produit un énorme bruit